The first time I saw the campus was...
It was incredible.
There's volleyball nets and colorful umbrellas and you see people walking their dogs.
It feels kind of like a playground.
A big playground.
The atmosphere around Google is definitely very eccentric but also very academic.
At Google, we actually do have the ability to make more of an impact on people...
...and more of a change in one year than many people do in their lifetimes.
It's an environment in which very few limitations are placed on...
...where your mind can be during the day.
You're all starting your teams this week,...
...and some great advice is to not be afraid to fail.
But we wanna flip that around a little bit and say, "Don't be afraid to succeed."